a marta morales la invade en los
recuerdos las pérdidas y las deudas
contraídas debido al confinamiento su
restaurante quebró y 19 familias se
quedaron sin sustento económico tener la
continuidad de un restaurante abierto
pues fue bastante trabajo lo que se hizo
se luchó y se mantuvo pero ahorita así
graves verán nos vemos así como martha
muchos empresarios tuvieron que cerrar
sus negocios pero se encuentra
oficialmente en recesión en el segundo
trimestre del año su producto bruto
interno se redujo en 30.2 por ciento
como consecuencia de la estricta
cuarentena impuesta para contener la
pandemia del cob y 19 las autoridades
han reconocido que el duro retroceso
para que este 2020 su economía tenga una
caída del 12% estamos en una recesión y
con un peligro de que se convierta en
una depresión que nos quedemos mucho
tiempo sin poder volver a crecer
normales no
esto porque hay un entrampamiento la
economía peruana casi 7 millones de
peruanos perdieron sus empleos los
expertos consideran que esto generará
más informalidad en el trabajo y mayor
pobreza los ciudadanos vislumbra un
futuro incierto están quebrando el
personal está siendo despedido los
hogares están en una situación económica
muy triste no hay para los alimentos de
la familia pero tener un comerciante
independiente
simplemente me quedé en la calle viejo
todo mi capital pero tengo que comer
porque no tiene trabajo no podía salir a
vender no puede hacer nada simplemente
me quedé me casé encerrado mes tres
meses para mí fue una decisión acertada
de la cuarentena ahora bien si eso
tenéis hay que aceptarlo no se hizo bien
muchas cosas no por ejemplo el tema de
la onu
marta ha decidido reinventarse como
consultora de belleza en la otra cara de
un perú que no se rinde ante la
adversidad